In this video, we'll take a look at how you can identify high-risk functionality with Burp Suite.
The target sitemap and proxy history within Burp can be used to identify high-risk functionality as you browse the target website.
This allows you to come up with a plan of attack for auditing the application.
Key areas to investigate include the application's core functionality,
security mechanisms such as authentication functions,
application behaviour such as error messages, admin functions and off-site links.
Before you start, you'll need to map your website.
Once the site has been mapped, review the sitemap under Target Sitemap.
By default, Burp Scanner passively audits traffic as you browse,
so you can look for the coloured circles on the nodes to show you where Burp Scanner has detected an issue.
You can also review the list of traffic in the proxy HTTP history tab.
When you identify functionality that you want to investigate further, keep the browser open and go to the proxy intercept tab in Burp.
Configure your interception settings to intercept the responses as well as the requests.
To do this, simply click on Settings, go to Tools, Proxy.
Under Response Interception Rules, select Intercept Response based on the following rules.
By default, responses with a content type header will now be intercepted.
Close the settings dialog.
Back in Burp's browser, we can now click through the function.
Burp will intercept each request and response, and you can review the messages for interesting content in the Intercept tab.
To flag and store a particular message for further investigation, you can right-click and send it to Burp Organiser.
To flag and store a particular message for further investigation.
To flag and store a particular message for further investigation, you can see the link in the description.